At CIFAR, we see research differently.
It's about more than proximity and disciplines
it's about asking the big questions
and assembling the right teams to find answers.
Being bold and taking risks
supporting diverse researchers who achieve unprecedented advances
in life and health
for individuals and society
for earth and space
for information and matter
for the world.
We support the risk-takers.
We enable big thinking.
We bring together the brightest and boldest minds across academic disciplines
and across borders
to address science and humanity's most important questions.
Together we stay curious
and we will continue to provide researchers with the  time and freedom to explore new ideas.
As we look to the future, we will work from this premise:
Fundamental research matters.
Some of it changes what we know about the world today,
and some of it will change what we know centuries from now.
All of it fuels innovation
and advanced humankind.
Join us.